BRING US TO ENERGY INDEPENDENCE?
PROBABLY NOTHING.
HERE NOW WITH MORE ON THE
SERIOUS ON GOING SITUATION AT
THE SOUTHERN BORDER, SOUTH
CAROLINA SENATOR, LINDSEY
GRAHAM.
YOU KNOW WHAT'S AMAZING, FIRST,
YOU SEE THE STATISTICS IN THE
OBAMA YEARS AND ALL THE TIMES
THEY USED TEAR GAS.
DO YOU REMEMBER ANY REPORTS, ANY
HYSTERIA FROM THE MEDIA ABOUT
THAT?
>> NUMBER ONE, NO.
HOW LONG DOES IT TAKE YOU TO
FIGURE THIS OUT?
WHETHER IT COME
WHETHER IT --ME
WHETHER IT -- WHEN IT COMES TO
OBAMA, WHEN HE USES TEAR GAS, HE
IS PROTECTING THE COUNTRY.
TRUMP IS A CRUEL, HEARTLESS
BASTARD AND IT UNDERCUTS THE
ARGUMENT THAT OBAMA USED IT TO
PROTECT OUR BORDER FROM BEING
OVERRUN.
WHAT DO YOU SAY TO THE PEOPLE
THAT SHOT THE CANISTERS?
I STAND BEHIND THE MEN AND WOMEN
ON THE BORDER STANDING BETWEEN
US AND PEOPLE THAT WANT TO CROSS
ILLEGALLY.
WHEN YOU ARE SLAMMING THE TEAR
GAS, YOU ARE SLAMMING THE PEOPLE
WE PUT ON THE BORDER TO PROTECT
US.
THAT'S WHAT DISGUSTS ME THE
MOST.
>> WHAT ARE THEY SUPPOSED TO DO,
WHEN ROCKING AND BOTTLES ARE
BEING PELTED AT THEM?
WHAT ARE WE SUPPOSED TO DO WHEN
THEY ARE BREAKING DOWN BARRIERS
AND WANT TO RUSH THE BORDER?
THIS IS WHAT WE WERE WARNING
ABOUT BEFORE THE ELECTION.
IT IS NOW COMING TO PASS.
THERE ARE THOUSANDS MORE STILL
COMING.
>> I HAVE BEEN A LAWYER IN THE
MILITARY MOST OF MY ADULT LIFE.
YOU USE THE LEAST AMOUNT OF
FORCE POSSIBLE TO PROTECT YOU
AND SECURE THE MISSION.
THE MISSION IS TO PROTECT THE
BORDER FROM BEING OVERRUN.
TEAR GAS KEEPS THE PEOPLE APART.
YOU DON'T GET IN A FIGHT.
THAT'S A GOOD THING.
THE BOTTOM LINE IS DONALD TRUMP
WAS RIGHT TO CALL THE CARAVAN
OUT WEEKS AGO.
HE IS RIGHT TO MAKE SURE IT
NEVER CROSSES THE BORDER.
PEOPLE THROUGHOUT THE WORLD ARE
WATCHING THE PRESIDENT.
IF HE BLINKS HERE, HIS
CREDIBILITY ON SECURING THE
BORDER IS DEAD.
HE IS NOT GOING TO BLINK.
TO MY DEMOCRATIC FRIENDS, HOW GO
YOU EXPECT THE PUBLIC TO WORK
WITH US TO FIX A BROKEN
IMMIGRATION SYSTEM IF YOU
SUPPORT ONE WAVE AFTER ANOTHER?
A LOT IS AT STAKE.
THE PRESIDENT IS NOT GOING TO
BEND OR BACK DOWN.
I HOPE THE REPUBLICANS AND
CONGRESS WILL STAND BEHIND HIM.
>
PRESIDENT OBAMA TEAR GASES
PEOPLE ON A MONTHLY BASIS.
WE WILL TALK TO KYRSTIN NEILSON.
WE HAVE IDENTIFIED AND MEXICO
HAS IDENTIFIED AT LEAST 500,
MAYBE 600 CRIMINALS COMING
ACROSS THAT BORDER THAT HAVE
INTEGRATED THEMSELVES INTO THE
MIGRANT POPULATION.
WHEN I SAT THROUGH A BRIEFING
WITH RICK PERRY IN TEXAS WHEN HE
WAS GOVERNOR, A SECURITY
BRIEFING THAT OBAMA SHOULD HAVE
BEEN AT, WHEN I SAT THROUGH IT,
THEY HAD A SEVEN-YEAR PERIOD OF
TIME, 642000 CRIMES COMMITTED
AGAINST TEXANS.
SOME MINOR, MANY SERIOUS,
INCLUDING MURDER.
I HAVE INTERVIEWED ANGEL MOMS
AND DADS MORE THAN I EVER WANTED
TO IN MY WHOLE LIFE, LOST THEIR
LIVES TO ILLEGAL IMMIGRANTS THAT
WE EVEN HAD IN OUR JUSTICE
SYSTEM AND NEVER DEPORTED.
AT WHAT POINT DOES THE
GOVERNMENT BEAR THE
RESPONSIBILITY THAT THEY DIDN'T
DO THEIR JOB AND ENFORCE THE
LAW?
WHAT CULPABILITY DO THEY HAVE?
>> I THINK WE HAVE A LOT OF
CULPABILITY AS A NATION FROM
IGNORING THIS PROBLEM.
DOING THE SAME OLD THING AND
EXPECTING A DIFFERENT OUTCOME IS
INSANITY.
PRESIDENT TRUMP IS GOING TO STOP
THE CARAVAN.
THE NEXT ONES COMING WON'T COME
IF THIS ONE IS STOPPED.
HE WILL SHUT DOWN THE BORDER IF
HE HAS TO.
DEMOCRATS SHOULD GIVE HIM THE
MONEY HE NEEDS TO SECURE THE
BORDER.
IF THEY DENY HIM THE FUNDING TO
SECURE OUR BORDER, PRESIDENT
TRUMP IS GOING TO PUSH BACK AND
FIGHT BACK.
THIS IS A DAY OF RECKONING FOR
THE AMERICAN PEOPLE.
WHAT MESSAGE DO YOU WANT TO SEND
TO THE REST OF THE WORLD ABOUT
OUR BORDER?
IF YOU WANT TO BE OPEN BORDERS,
THIS IS YOUR CHANCE.
IF YOU WANT TO STAND FIRM, THIS
IS ALSO YOUR OPPORTUNITY AND I
HOPE DEMOCRATS UNDERSTAND YOU
HAVE GOT TO REALLY HATE TRUMP TO
NOT SEE THIS CARAVAN IS A
PROBLEM FOR THE AMERICAN PEOPLE.
>> LET ME ASK YOU A LAST
QUESTION ABOUT MUELLER.
THE PRESIDENT SAID HE IS NOT
GOING TO STOP THIS, NEVER HAD
ANY PLANS.
HE SAID IT NUMEROUS TIMES NOW.
AT THIS POINT, HOW DO WE JUSTIFY
AS A NATION THAT BELIEVES IN A
CONSTITUTIONAL REPUBLIC.
WE AGREE IN EQUAL APPLICATION OF
OUR LAWS, EQUAL JUSTICE UNDER
THE LAW AND HILLARY USED PAID
FOR PHONEY RUSSIANS LIES TO
INFLUENCE THE AMERICAN PEOPLE.
THAT WAS USED AS A FRAUD ON THE
FISA COURT, WOULD NEVER VERIFY
OR CORROBORATED.
HILLARY NEVER IDENTIFIED AS
HAVING PAID FOR IT.
THEN IT GOES FURTHER AND IT IS
USED AS PART OF A LEAK STRATEGY.
THE BULK OF INFORMATION
ACCORDING TO YOURS AND CHARLES
SGRA
GRASSLEY'S MEMO.
WHY HAS MUELLER, IF HE CARES
ABOUT RUSSIAN INTERFERENCE, SHE
PAID FOR IT, WHY IS THAT NOT AN
ISSUE?
>> YOU CAN'T BLAME MUELLER.
IT IS NOT HIS CHARTER TO LOOK AT
THAT.
I DO BLAME --
>> WHOA.
WHY IS IT NOT?
IF HE IS LOOKING FOR RUSSIA
COLLUSION, WHY IS THAT NOT
WITHIN HIS MANDATE WHETHER
SOMEBODY'S LOAN APPLICATION IS
WITHIN HIS MANDATE?
>> IT MIGHT BE.
I BLAME THE DEPARTMENT OF
JUSTICE FOR NOT APPOINTING A
SPECIAL COUNSEL TO LOOK AT THE
FISA WARRANT.
THEY GOT AWAY WITH A LOT HERE.
IF I'M CHAIRMAN OF THE COMMITTEE
NEXT YEAR, WE ARE GOING TO LOOK
AT FISA WARRANT PROGRAM.
>> COULD WE GET TO THE BOTTOM OF
HILLARY'S E-MAILS AND
DESTRUCTION OF E-MAILS?
>> WE NEED A SPECIAL COUNSEL TO
LOOK AT THIS.
DID THEY HAVE A POLITICAL BIAS?